the 2022 mtv movie and tv awards
returned to barker hanger in santa
monica last night with vanessa hudgins
hosting the star-studded evening and can
we just take a moment for her not one oh
no but seven looks throughout the night
including this stunning vera wang mini
dress she wore on the red carpet i like
it she had the whole like that's a
moment you need to have the train kind
of blowing in the wind like that when
the wind is going she's like this is
it's working it's working it's happening
look at me i'm going to put my head down
i'm going to look over here look at that
oh up hi it just wow here's the thing
here's my one thing i will say whenever
video is rolling when someone is trying
to take a picture you look ridiculous
and we always use it on our show of
someone at a photo wall where you're
supposed to just pose and get your
picture right but then we roll the video
and they look crazy so like this right
it's like i know but we're so used to
seeing it now but then when you see the
photos they're so beautiful this is what
you have to do to get those kind of
iconic looks yeah i love this vanessa
went for an entirely different vibe
though for her last look of the night
putting a really fun twist on catwoman
in the skin tight cat suit paired with a
red bright wig
oh morgan what do you think oh i love
this look i this might be my favorite
look like don't get me wrong i love that
blue dress that gown on the red carpet
but this is great i mean it's a lot of
looks it's a lot of pressure hosting an
event like that and the fact that she's
like getting back and forth and trying
all the different looks on this this she
was a knockout for me she was such a
stamina this last year though she's
really made a huge comeback yeah not
that she totally disappeared but just i
i feel like every time there's an event
or a red carpet i see her who's she's
amazing i don't know anyway whoever her
stylist is you're hitting it out of the
park she looks amazing and euphoria star
sydney sweeney showed off her mid-drift
in this crystal beaded low rise mini
skirt paired with a pink crop top mew
mew um was this a hit for you morgan
guys this hurts my soul i'm gonna call
this a miss but here's the thing she
looks amazing i mean look at how tone
that stomach is i could only imagine um
she looks fantastic i know the whole low
rise skirt is in i just i don't get it
but i'm also not cool so
and she is but you are cool you are cool
i don't know i just i know that like the
whole low rise early 2000s but like i
went i lived through that and i'm still
scarred from it but i appreciate that
she can pull it off i don't know i
prefer a low rise
because when you sit in mom jeans or
anything mom-ish you can't breathe
that's actually a good point and your
ribs hurt and you get a stomachache and
then cramps it's not good and low-rise
at least there's things can move okay
anyway how did we get here i don't know
is i don't know i agree with you that
the top maybe didn't match the bottom
yeah but i don't know if that worked but
she looks amazing on every red carpet
i'm such a big fan of hers as an actress
not just from euphoria but basically
every project that she's done
so i can't say too much
about her because she's great she looks
great it's just not for me that's all
all right now we also have to talk about
the big moment of the night uh jennifer
lopez she accepted the generation award
and also won best song for on my way
from her latest rom-com marry me yes
j-lo opted for a black leather look
wearing this plunging vest paired with a
long
curved hugging skirt
so listen
listen that low plunge hello jlo you can
pull that off the leather i love it she
looks incredible you're not gonna hear
me say she doesn't look good however
overall with the looks maybe aside from
vanessa hudgens i kind of felt everybody
a little underwhelmed i don't know i
expect kind of like fun and over the top
but uh she looked incredible what did
you think i think jlo is similar to you
i mean there's nothing that she i just i
don't love let leather i've never had
really love when i wear leather i get
hives when i i just i have a heart
no but i don't know i didn't i didn't
love it as much but i loved the cutout
in the lower back i thought that was
super sexy yeah but it wasn't my
favorite and her speech was beautiful i
loved how she said about real love
and also talking about how those people
i mean i think you can agree most of us
right in our careers there's been lots
of people who said you can't you will
never make it you will never do it and i
loved how
she called those people out and said
thank you because that pushed me
to
be more go past my comfort zone which i
think i know i've had it i know you've
had it we've talked about this before i
definitely have i've had moments where
i've questioned maybe i should be on tv
you know like or maybe i shouldn't be
talking an entertainment or maybe i
shouldn't because someone had said
something and then you know if you love
what you're doing just keep going you
just keep going yeah absolutely so i
loved her speech i thought it was
beautiful yeah all right now olivia
rodrigo also in black can we talk about
this look i like this look wearing a
halter neck corset dress by paul gautier
styled with a 2000s inspired hairdo
seriously the whole y2k looks are coming
back can i just say she's giving some
major jenna rink vibes and if you don't
know that name is from 13 going on 30.
she liked the exact same hairstyle that
jennifer garner wore loved all of that
yeah i think she looks great so fun and
we can't forget about paris hilton who
looked
quite gorgeous in the sky blue maxi gown
featuring swarovski crystals and a thigh
high slit but morgan what did you think
of the silver gloves she's been wearing
gloves a lot lately yeah so i don't get
it i don't know if there's a need for it
but i love her in them like they're
sparkly they go with the dress i love
the blue
i think she looks stunning and what's
interesting is i didn't actually see as
many photos of her swirling around on
social media as everybody else but when
i saw this blue i was like yes and the
gloves still don't get it but i dig it
so the gloves i think every time she
dj's she has the gloves on i think cool
okay anybody want to write it and tell
me if i'm right or wrong um but i think
i think
i mean madonna made the gloves did the
gloves i mean 100 yeah it's just yeah i
don't know if i would have ever thought
of pairing sparkly gloves with that
beautiful blue gown
it makes it a little edgier right but
she can totally pull it off okay so
jennifer's saying jlo is amazing
yeah she does look good good kenzie's
agreeing with you how very madonna yeah
which is awesome uh and so will studio
saying low rise and mom jeans i hope
there are more options than that
you can wear track pants track pants are
always a go i feel like track pants were
last year though and i don't know if
there's no they're going to be this year
i am not letting it be last year because
i have more tie-dyed track suits than i
can shake a stick at and
i just sounded like my mom there shake a
stick